dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on alpha here as
machine learning research advances over
time learning based techniques are
getting better and better at generating
images or even creating videos when
given a topic a few episodes ago we
talked about deep Minds dual video
discriminator technique in which
multiple neural networks compete against
each other
teaching our machines to synthesize a
collection of two-second long videos one
of the key advantages of this method was
that it learned the concept of changes
in the camera view zooming in on an
object and understood that if someone
draws something with a pen the ink has
to remain on the paper and changed
however generally if we wish to ask an
AI to synthesize assets for us we'll
likely have an exact idea of what we are
looking for in these cases we are
looking for a little more artistic
control then this technique offers us so
can we get around this if so how well we
can I tell you how in a moment but to
understand this solution we first have
to have a firm grasp on the concept of
latent spaces you can think of a latent
space as a compressed representation
that tries to capture the essence of the
data set that we have at hand you can
see a similar latent space method in
action here that set different kinds of
fonts apart and presents these options
on a 2d plane and here you see our
technique that builds a little space for
modeling a wide range of photorealistic
material models that we can explore
and now onto this new work what this
tries to do is find a path in the latent
space of these images that relates to
intuitive concepts like camera zooming
rotation or shifting that's not an easy
task but if we pull it off we'll have
more artistic control over these
generated images which will be immensely
useful for many creative tasks this new
work can perform that and not only that
but it is also able to learn the concept
of color enhancement and can even
increase or decrease the contrast of
these images the key idea of this paper
is that this can be done through trying
to find crazy nonlinear trajectories in
these latent spaces that happen to
relate to these intuitive concepts it is
not perfect in a sense that we can
indeed zoom in on the picture of this
dog but the posture of the dog also
changes and it even seems like we are
starting out with a puppy that grows up
frame by frame this means that we have
learned to navigate this latent space
but there is still some additional fat
in these movements which is a typical
side effect of latent space based
techniques and also don't forget that
the training data the AI is given also
has its own limits however as you see we
are now one step closer to not only
having an AI that synthesizes images for
us but one that does it exactly with the
camera setup rotation and colors that we
are looking for what a time to be alive
if you wish to see beautiful
formulations of walks walks in latent
spaces that is make sure to have a look
at the paper in the video description
also note that we have now appeared on
Instagram with bite-sized pieces of our
bite-sized videos yes it is quite
peculiar make sure to check it out just
search for 2 minute papers on Instagram
or click the link in the video
description thanks for watching and for
your generous support and I'll see you
next time